[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with journalist and
author rachel shabby and the director of
communications at the institute of
economic affairs annabelle denham
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the sunday express leads with boris
johnson saying that joining the pacific
trading block will mean lower prices in
supermarkets
the observer's front page has a report
that labor has surged in the polls amid
senior conservatives fears over liz
truss's tax cut
the sunday telegraph leads with a report
that conservative leadership candidate
liz trust has pledged to halt doctors
leaving the nhs to tackle the coveted
backlog and surging waiting lists
waste minster is the sunday mirror
headline with the paper reporting that
more than a thousand tons of subsidized
food has been dumped at westminster
the sunday times reports that university
bosses are calling for a tuition fee
rise
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by rachel
shabby and annabelle denham welcome to
you both let's start with the observer
first of all
and uh this surge in the polls for labor
they're reporting uh rachel you take us
into this first
sure so this is looking at um
so first of all
liz truss's fortunes are going down but
concurrently labors are shooting up so
over the last few weeks i guess um what
michael gove has referred to as um you
know trust being divorced taking a
holiday from reality and i would say is
completely and utterly detached from the
reality that most people are living in
today
i guess more exposure to that is making
people perhaps go off her but at the
same time
um in the last week
kierstama's own personal ratings as well
as the labour party's fortunes have both
dramatically shot up according to this
new poll cited in the observance by
servation and i think we can put this
down to
uh stoma's announcement a week ago that
energy prices would be capped and it
just shows you it's just one thing one
little thing i mean it is significant
um this promise to
cap energy prices at a time when 45
million people in this country
will go into some kind of fuel poverty
according to a survey a few days ago um
because of the
spikes in energy prices
but it is probably worth noting at the
same time that while even just that
shift has significantly
turbo boosted labour's fortunes there is
overwhelming public support for
renationalization of the big five energy
companies um that's according to another
servation poll done for we own it um
most conservative voters as well as
three quarters of uh labour party voters
would back renationalizing energy
companies and it's hard to look at the
scale of this crisis the record profits
that these companies are making
basically profiteering off the general
public's misery it's hard to look at
that reality
and not see that really taking back
public control public ownership of these
energy companies is the best way not as
in not just to fix our immediate crisis
but in the long term as well
uh annabelle it's probably fair to say
that it hasn't helped liz truss's
fortunes uh when uh erstwhile colleagues
like michael gove a conservative member
and a cabinet member previously he's
saying that her plans to focus on
cutting taxes is a holiday from reality
no certainly that would have been a a
knock to her
campaign but it's certainly not going to
be a coup de grace let's not forget that
she has overwhelmingly the support of
current cabinet ministers in fact i'm
not sure that rishi has been endorsed by
any uh current cabinet ministers at
least not since he got down to
the final two i think that liz trusts is
running into some trouble now as beyond
cutting taxes she doesn't really have a
solution to addressing the cost of
living crisis the fact that households
are going to be really squeezed uh
particularly as uh perhaps liz trust or
perhaps usually like assume office this
is not a good time to be coming into
number 10 downing street as prime
minister it's going to be immensely
difficult for them um as well um you
know interesting here how it talks about
uh high-ranking conservatives panicking
about the tory prospects at the next
general election let's not forget that
polls have shown that among those who
voted conservative at the last general
election not conservative
members necessarily but the wider public
rishi sunak is more popular so liz trust
may get the keys to number 10 but that
she may struggle to get
retain her position come 2024 if indeed
that's when the next general election is
called now i mean you can argue that we
are currently midterm we might expect
the tories to be falling behind but
until partygate the tories had never
been consistently behind in the polls
during this government they uh boris
johnson and the party defied political
gravity in the way that tony blair did
so i don't think we can assume that the
tories are a safe political bet for the
next election in the way that we perhaps
might have done 12 months ago yes and
the the article points to the fact that
two weeks ago 29 of all voters said
trust would be the best pm against 28
who chose stammer today trust has
dropped to
23 percent
um let us move on to the telegraph and
have a look at the um energy cap hitting
6k
um
that's their
front story quessy quartens planning a
crackdown on wind and solar energy
profits that's um while the the energy
cap is going to hit 6k
rachel
i mean i i find this a really obtuse way
into the story from the telegraph i mean
what we are looking at ultimately is is
eye-watering um energy prices because
the cap has is is increasing
um it is true that according to this
piece as this piece says um
[Music]
renewables the price of them is is just
as high because it is currently pegged
to electricity and gas prices so they
all go up at the same time
but
this again seems to me an argument free
renationalization i mean that would
allow
um the record profits that are made when
companies go back into making so if you
take back if you take back companies
into re-national if you renationalize
the big five let's say
they wouldn't immediately make a profit
because you'd be capping their prices so
that people would be able to afford to
pay their fuel bills and not fall into
destitution or worse
right but once when they go back into
making a profit because they're under
public ownership you could then decide
actually we're going to funnel those
profits into renewables we're going to
funnel them into wind sources we're
going to fund them into other renewable
sources so that you're not because
you're not beholden to shareholders
anymore
or
you know record um
bonuses to your fat cat bosses so it
completely changes the calibration
of the energy equation and i think
that's the story we should be getting at
i'm not really sure i understand what
the telegraph is getting at uh with this
piece annabelle what did you read into
the story
sure well i think that the conservative
government is very much on the wrong
course when it it's looking at these
windfall taxes first on oil and gas
companies the energy profits levy that
was announced earlier this year when
rishi sunak was chance of the exchequer
and now we have quasi-puerton who is
picked to be the next chancellor should
liz trust uh be successful in early
september he's now planning a crackdown
on wind and solar energy profits uh as
the energy price cap which
the expectations for which seem to be
revised upwards and upwards
virtually on a daily basis um now now
this is not the way to address the the
current energy crisis by uh taxing these
companies and forcing them to operate in
increasingly unstable tax regimes we're
going to discourage investment and we're
going to prevent new entrants from
coming into the sector thereby stifling
competition but nonetheless this seems
to be the path that the conservatives
are going down i expect that this
response uh this announcement from the
business secretary is in part a response
to
kierstama's uh support for freezing
prices um certainly you can see the
appeal for that and that it would be
simple it would send a message to
consumers that the government has their
backs and this is probably what the
business secretary is is trying to
demonstrate but the problem with
freezing prices is that it interferes
with price signals and at the moment we
have a big difference between supply and
demand and we need market signals to to
correct that uh we also have the problem
that most of the benefit of freezing
prices would go to those who are bigger
users this would not be a highly
targeted measure and that's absolutely
what the government needs to be looking
at because the public finances are in a
pretty polished state so it needs to
address how it cushions the blow of
soaring energy prices of rising
inflation for the most vulnerable rather
than issuing uh handouts to the public
at large
rachel to the observer and they've got a
story about libraries and museums
bracing themselves for crowds of people
flocking to them to keep warm as the
winter months approach
well that's right and it's still still
an energy and heating story so i do want
to respond briefly to what annabelle
just said because actually it makes
absolutely no sense and the reason we
know that is because we can just look
across the water to france where energy
is fully nationalized edf is fully
nationalized owned by the french public
and energy bills rose just by four four
percent this year that's what you're
able to do when you control your own
energy um but yes libraries and museums
and other public spaces are now
looking to be potential places where
people who cannot afford to heat their
own homes
will
converge they will become warm havens to
people who can't afford to heat their
homes and the government is being
encouraged to
push funding in their direction because
obviously museums
libraries etc are also going to be
experiencing huge spikes in um
in
energy bills as well so there's a call
there for the government to
help them out but again this does seem
to be
we keep scrabbling about for different
ways to tackle this problem oh and have
people go to libraries or you know
another front page story is looking at
people who switch off their appliances
and use smart meters being rewarded for
doing so but these are all like
plasters on top of a
bleeding gaping wound none of this gets
to the heart of the problem the problem
at the moment
isn't
just the energy prices are going up it's
that the companies that are private are
running them at extortionate profits
they are spiking their their rates for
their own private gain that cannot be
allowed to happen at a time when you
will then have 45 million people plunged
into fuel poverty the answer to that
seems to me staring us in the face let's
just quickly bring annabelle in we've
just got a few a minute or so i think
left um
is it right that it is a sticking
plaster on a gaping wound to suggest
that we heat libraries and and museums
more so people can go there rather than
solving the the initial problem
yes certainly it that's absolutely the
right definition to to call it a
sticking plaster but look we have to
weather this storm um over the next 12
months or so until we hope energy prices
do begin to come down let's not forget
that they are in large part down to the
uh conflict in ukraine and
the government needs to
implement measures that are going to
protect those who are most vulnerable
perhaps through the benefit systems
through income transfers to help them
get through this winter i don't you know
i don't think it's a bad idea to be
suggesting that people go to areas where
they can be warm even though we don't
want to be in a situation where that's
required when we don't want to be in a
situation where people are choosing
between heating and eating and having to
ration the amount of energy that they're
using but you know over the longer term
we absolutely need deregulation of the
energy sector which is what we had in
the 1990s we had a massive program of
deregulation and privatization and that
led to a significant drop in prices for
consumers as well as a drop in the
amount of emissions uh relatively
speaking so that that's the longer term
strategy but certainly in the short term
i think the government is is clutching
its straws it's trying to do all it can
to perhaps adjust our behavior and and
find places that people can go if
they're unable to heat their homes okay
annabelle and rachel uh thank you both i
can see there is a little bit of
disagreement there but i think you you
came round to
to agreeing on that that one point um
today with us we're going to take a
break more on our press preview
including this story on the front of the
telegraph their headline trusts i'll
halt nhs doctor exodus do stay with us
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me journalist and
author rachel shabby and the director of
communications at the institute of
economic affairs annabelle denham
welcome back to both of you let's take a
look at the telegraph front page first
of all rachel and the quote is i'll halt
nhs doctor exodus this is a quote from
liz trust how exactly is she planning to
do this do we learn in this article
um
it's a very good question and to be
honest i'm not sure liz trust herself
knows the answer it's worth just hoping
back to the
um the revelation a few days ago that
truss
um
co-authored a paper in support of cuts
to the nhs and cuts to doctors pay so i
don't know if by cutting pay she plans
to bring more staff back to the nhs but
here she's talking about um
[Music]
re-jigging the
current rules on
pensions
so that
um
because of the pen because pensions are
basically there's a safety net around
them for doctors correctly i think for
nhs staff if they start to earn beyond
that
um then they'll get taxed
taxed to the point where they're
actually paying to work so i think
that's the bit of regulation that she's
looking at um
it's worth pointing out in this piece it
refers to because the nhs is in such a
terrible state with you know record
ambulance response times record waiting
times
um you know staff shortages
there's now 1 000 excess deaths a week
as a result of all that which is
actually more than a number of people
um
just due to covet so that's quite an
eye-watering figure in itself but
obviously if you talk to anyone from the
nhs as opposed to this trust and the
regulation slashing fundamentalists that
that she surrounds herself with they
would say um
things like you know deal with nhs
burnout and stress levels post covid
increase capacity like bed capacity
increase
capacity for emergency lines like 9-1-1
and 1-1-1
increase international recruitment um
invest heavily in mental health all of
those things i would imagine would come
up if you actually asked somebody who
works in the nhs as opposed to someone
who uh doesn't seem that connected to
the reality of the nhs like this trust
annabelle she seems to be suggesting
remodeling the the nhs pension scheme
and that being a solution to a senior
staff
leaving at uh great rates
well certainly i think that that could
ease some of the pressures that the nhs
is currently facing i don't think it's a
panacea to the fact that we've got over
six million people on the nhs uh waiting
list yeah so this is trust you want to
address the fact that doctors are given
this lifetime cap on pensions and are
subject to taxes when they make pay uh
payments that exceed it which it's a
perversion in in the tax system it
incentivizes these doctors um to retire
early rather than working for longer and
we know thanks to that rather alarming
report from the health and social care
committee last month
that we are facing a workforce crisis
across health and social care um the
research was from the nuffield trust um
and found that nhs england is short of 2
12 12 000 hospital doctors and and many
thousands more nurse nurses and midwives
i know that the across the oecd they're
expecting around a 400 000 doctor
shortage by 2030 and that means we're
going to be competing internationally to
attract more doctors to come here or
indeed doctors who've been trained in
the uk to stay and work here um you know
so as rachel said it
barely a day passes at the moment
without us reading about the nhs being
in crisis be it ambulance waiting times
be it the number of uh patients who are
dying every week um and something
absolutely needs to be done and this is
this is an attempt one that i would
support to at least in part solve the
problems facing the nhs annabelle thank
you sorry we must leave it there we've
run out of time thank you both